this morning the US Virgin Islands are
also under hurricane watch CBS News
climate and weather contributor Jeff
bear Adelie is here tracking Dorion Jeff
where else in the u.s. is a storm likely
how did you think so view are located on
the southeast coast pay very close
attention to the system a lot has
changed since last night let's talk
about it look at the storm you can see a
big blowup of thunderstorms on the
northeastern side that's the stronger
side it is shifted east it's a little
stronger than it was last night winds
are 60 miles an hour it's moving
Northwest notice the system is likely
probably to pass just to the east of
Puerto Rico that means the worst of it
over the Virgin Islands Puerto Rico is
on the better side but still heavy rain
and gusty winds and power outages are
possible that's the official forecast
track moves near Puerto Rico this
afternoon winds around 70 miles an hour
just short of a hurricane but look at
this it moves over a very nurturing
environment for strengthening across the
Bahamas and towards Florida reaches the
florida area by sunday monday now
predicted to be a category 2 storm we
put our spaghetti model plots on some
actually take it along the coast and not
into Northeast Florida it's gonna miss
the big mountains of Haiti and the
Dominican Republic that means it
maintains its strength look at how hot
the water is there it's forecast to be a
cat 2 it could easily be a major
hurricane cat 3 or more pay close
attention
all right Jeff thank you a lot to worry
about there